[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOE KAVA: I love building
in operating data centers.
I'm Joe Kava, Vice President
of Data Centers at Google.
I'm responsible for managing
the teams globally that design,
build, and operate
Google's data centers.
We're also responsible for
the environmental health
and safety, sustainability,
and carbon offsets for our data
centers.
This data center here
in South Carolina
is one node in a larger
network of data centers
all over the world.
Of all the employees at Google,
a very, very small percentage
of those employees are
authorized to even enter
a data center campus.
I think the Google
data centers really
can offer a level of security
that almost no other company
can match.
We have a information
security team
that is truly second to none.
You have the expression,
they wrote the book on that.
Well, there are many of
our information security
team members that
have really written
the books on best practices
in information security.
Protecting the security
and the privacy
of our users' information is
our foremost design criteria.
We use various layers
of higher-level security
the closer into the center
of the campus you get.
So just to enter
this campus, my badge
had to be on a
pre-authorized access list.
Then, to come into
the building, that
was another level of security.
To get into the secure corridor
which leads to the data center,
that's a higher
level of security.
And the data center and
the networking rooms
are the highest
level of security.
All of our racks don't really
look like a traditional server
rack.
These are custom designed
and built for Google
so that we can
optimize the servers
for hyper-efficiency and
high-performance computing.
To me, the thing that amazes
me about Google and the data
centers is the
pace of innovation
and always challenging the
way we're doing things.
So when people say that
innovation in a certain area
is done, that we've, kind of,
reached the pinnacle of what
can be achieved, I just laugh.
[MUSIC PLAYING]